this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman this first
email comes from Pater I guess that's
Peter in Swedish PE d er Peter in
Stockholm Sweden Stockholm I'm long time
listo and loves the show let's stop it
you're not on my side
[ __ ] good-looking young waiter huh
yeah drink this old man ha ha ha ha
I will have your [ __ ] job I am not
kidding I know people in this place I
think it's very revealing that you drank
a shot and all of a sudden you're
noticing the boy waiters and [ __ ] look
at that good-looking waiter what's our
problem
stop bringing me shots marry Peter from
Stockholm Sweden as I was saying that is
not a Swedish accent Swedish accent is
borscht borscht now that's the
stereotypical Muppets we know that
Swedish man
I have too much t-shirts so it did a
garment tattoo instead not the nicest
tat it's kind of hard to do on yourself
holy shitty self to himself tatted my
face on his leg because he thought he
already had too many t-shirts so he
didn't buy a garmi t-shirt
he took the garmi image and [ __ ]
tattooed it permanently on his body
Lucy Lucy we got a picture of the the
home tat version of me 2 points oh
that's fresh fresh ink that's a pretty
good job for a self tattoo cuz he had to
do it upside down right cuz that's his
knee I think unless he's John Merrick
the Elephant Man that is really good
though pretty good for a self Ted how
does it make you feel man creep the [ __ ]
out really I know you run to this all
time there's a ton of people have you
and J and stuff tattooed all over their
body but that just anyone who'd do that
permanent art on their body as a tribute
to something that I do is just way too
over-the-top
it makes me very uncomfortable that
would bum you out if that person came
through their leg up on the [ __ ]
table it was like look at it look at the
devotion garmi garma kisser
kiss the sacred I would know it bothered
me would seriously but this but just the
picture doing that he did it bothers me
good thing he's in Sweden poor dudes get
a [ __ ] here to show his like fourth
port spork
[Music]
you